في السودان تجري منذ اسابيع محادثات بين
قوى الحريه والتغيير والجيش في مسحا لكسر
الجنود السياسي في مؤتمر صحفي قالت القوه
ان العمل جاري التواصل الى اتفاق وصفاته
بالايطالي لتشكيل حكومه المدنيه
وهو ايضا هدفه الثاني اقامه السلطه مدنيه
ديمقراطيه المحادثات بين الطرفين ستستمر
لبحث عده قضايا حددتها قوه الحريه
والتغيير بالعداله الانتقاليه ومراجعه
اتفاق جوبا للسلام وتفكيك النظام الرئيسي
السابق عمر البشير واصلاح الامن والجيش
مواضيع شائكه ولا سيما مع تاكيدات قائد
الجيش بانه لم يسمح لاحد بتدخل في المؤسسه
العسكريه ومنذ انقلاب عبد الفتاح البرهان
على المكون المدني في مجلس السياده في
العام الماضي دخل السودان ومازقا سياسيا
وتفاقمه مشكلاته الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
نفوض الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان دعا الى
استعاده الحكم المدنيه
الاطراف المشاركه في العمليه السياسيه الى
بدل المزيد من الجهود من اجل استعاده
الحكم المدني سريعا ويبقى التحدي الاكبر
في اشراك مزيدا من الفاعلين السياسيين في
المحادثات حيث ترفض العديد من الاطراف
الحوار مع الجيش
على جهود الامم المتحده في الوساطه بين
القاده العسكريين والمدنيين